[Music]
[Applause]
marcus spears espn nfl analyst and uh
contributes to getup and nfl live and
other programs you can see them with dan
arlovsky meenakim's ryan clark laura
rutledge every weekday 4 eastern
and uh you got football coming up
monday's mega cast it'll be the
cardinals and the rams available on the
espn plus marcus great to have you back
are you a no chance guy when it comes to
like the steelers against the chiefs or
the eagles against the buccaneers
because i called out
rob ninkovich he said the eagles have no
chance well
if if the eagles win the game nikovich
should sit down for a week he should be
suspended for a week
all right
he should dp he should and i'm i i am
absolutely not a no chance guy i played
in this league i've been playing
football too long since peewee football
in south baton rouge louisiana to know
that teams have no chance okay now now
there there are there are different
levels to no chance dp you remember
those games when you were in like middle
school and nobody was over four foot ten
and your whole basketball team was like
five seven and above that's when you
have no chance but in the nfl based on
what we've seen hey adp i bet he would
have said the jacksonville jaguars had
no chance against the coach yeah the
last week of the season yeah you know
what i'm saying so i bet he would have
said the jets had no chance last year to
beat the las vegas raiders at the end of
the game last year so look i i uh
i have always been one of those guys
that looks at matchups that looks at
individual performances and if you got a
guy like tj white on your team you got a
chance
and and i keep telling people that and
that doesn't mean that they're gonna win
the game
but the pittsburgh steelers have a
chance because they in the playoffs and
and i'm telling you week nine everybody
probably said they had no chance in hell
to get into the postseason so i'm not a
no chance guys when you go into the
playoffs as a uh former defensive player
is it spoken about trying to take the
opposing quarterback out
like you get it
not out no not out i mean if it happens
we're not mad about it
let me say that if it happens we're not
bad about it but it's a healthy respect
man you know how i go uh the in the game
has changed i'm sure
guys back in the old days would would
have would have said yes to that but
when i played we wanted to we wanted to
rough them up enough where they couldn't
be as effective as they were but taking
them out if it if it's happenstance then
we we are not going to cry any tears
about it like when i was in the division
with with the cowboys i wouldn't have
been mad if we knocked donovan mcnair
about the game i wouldn't have been mad
if we knocked eli out of the game and
i'm bringing up guys that stopped me
from getting to the playoffs dan so i'm
still kind of scared
but that feeling did you ever feel sorry
for a quarterback during a game
hell no
hell no i ain't even feel sorry for our
home
we we are out there
banging i'm a defensive lineman we out
there banging 60 plus plays a game you
know and the quarterback get hit and
everybody has a moment of silence and
the whole stadium got to exit and
re-enter the stadium to make sure
everybody's okay ain't give a damn about
no quarterbacks getting hurt or all
roughed up i didn't care
all right give me the underdog with the
best chance of winning
san francisco 49ers and you know how
much i love the dallas cowboys uh but
the brand of football that they play
it's just difficult to
sustain
the level that you need to sustain for
four quarters when they gonna keep
coming downhill they're gonna be
physical they're gonna stick to that
gameplay they went down 17 nothing to
the rams last week and never changed
their identity one bit i will say this
though dp
i really want the dallas cowboys to put
this game in jimmy garoppolo's hands i
feel comfortable with that um the
and and look i'm not a i'm not a jimmy g
detractor i'm just not a a jimmy g lover
i i don't trust jimmy garoppolo like a
lot of people trust him when people say
my body physically bp when people say
jimmy garoppolo led the 49ers to a super
bowl i
break out in hives listening to it you
mean the guy that threw eight passes in
the nfc championship led a football team
to a championship so if if you allow
these guys to be you know the word
that's been thrown around is physicality
then let me tell you something bro
everybody in the damn nfl physical
you ain't getting them checks or them
direct deposits every week if you're not
physical you just have to last
long most teams don't force you to play
the run like the san francisco 49ers do
for an entire game and you just got to
make your mind up that you're going to
be disciplined the whole way but if
jimmy garoppolo has it in his hands i'll
be drinking this clear cup of coffee
watching the game
dp does this make me look like like a
like a small rich person with a clear
yeah
if if you're if your pinky finger goes
up marcus
yeah you look a little soft
okay i mean nobody's gonna say it to
your face but i can say it via zoom you
look soft
i'm looking at the quarterbacks with the
most pressure
yeah and
i know where i would start i think this
guy's got the most pressure i'm i'm
curious
who you think the quarterback who will
be under the most pressure playoff time
dp this is one this one gonna shock you
because the the normal is matthew
stafford i think that's been like the
overall
aaron rodgers
has anybody ever thought about that
has anybody watched how that offseason
transpired
the the only way
to keep this noise quiet is to go win
the super bowl cause look aaron is has
played at the mvp level i think he's the
mvp and by the way aaron aaron is not my
favorite guy okay i don't love to see
what aaron rodgers is talking about but
i do have a healthy respect for how he's
been able to keep his game at this level
and he's been able to carry a team for a
long time
but dp
we sitting here not knowing after a
restructured contract if he's gonna
return to green bay
he spent an entire offseason at odds
with the franchise
he needed players so they relented and
brought in around the cob even though
randall cobb has been hurt they made
some concessions for him does anybody
think about aaron rodgers responsibility
to the green bay packers and the rest of
this football team we expect him to at
least make it to the nfc championship
and that's where the buck has stopped
for him for so many years he got to get
to a super bowl and win it man or
at some point we gotta say like we do
for every other star
he couldn't get it done
he just couldn't get it done
yeah i i agree with you i think matthew
stafford and josh allen are one two on
my list
now i would i would put dak prescott in
there just because he's the quarterback
of the cowboys i think the cowboys are a
year ahead of schedule i
because i don't know if they knew what
they had in diggs and micah parsons now
they realize that and you don't want to
miss out on this opportunity um
i you know ben doesn't have any pressure
on him uh joe burrow doesn't have
pressure on him derek carr doesn't have
pressure on him
brady always has pressure but it feels
like he he wants the pressure now he's
an underdog he didn't get the mvp now
he's an underdog he got a chip on his
shoulder i i i love that i just don't
know how good they are because that
defense hasn't been what it was in the
super bowl um
bp i tell people all the time it's okay
it's not taboo to say aaron rodgers is
under pressure like
how many years did we spend talking
about drew brees in order to enter the
conversation of the greats we know aaron
talon is unbelievable but in order for
drew to enter the conversation of the
greats to have him be a part of the
all-time top five or whatever you want
to put in conversation he needed more
than one aaron rodgers has been stopped
in the nfc championship a lot yeah now
imagine if this was imagine if this was
uh
a lebron james getting stopped in the
eastern or western conference finals all
of these times the conversation that
will go on imagine if this was the
yankees when steinbrenner and they had
all of this talent and spent all of this
money and they couldn't make it out of
the conference um out of the series so i
i don't i don't i don't necessarily
equate pressure to if a guy is going to
have the rest of his career or if he's
going to be good i equate pressure to
how did you perform
what is expected of you and then in
aaron's case he entered a different
nuance by the battle between him and the
green bay package this all season so
i mean i think it's a failure if they
don't win a super bowl it was all about
nothing
well i look at the packers in 2020 13
wins
20 21 13 wins the defense in 2020
ranked 13th
this year's team ranked 13th in defense
you have home field advantage
that tampa team that if they do come to
town will not be as formidable as they
were a year ago
and aaron has not done well in in title
games even when he's hosted those title
games well peyton manning went through
this as well
where you know peyton's playoff record
wasn't very good but
um do we hold quarterbacks uh you know
accountable in a different way than we
do other athletes in in other sports
because you mentioned lebron and you
know that there's certain sports or you
know baseball pitchers players but when
it comes to quarterbacks uh our bottom
line is winning championships
but i think people don't realize how
aaron has not performed or at least the
packers haven't when they get to the nfc
title game they're not dp because
they're blinded by all of the greatness
in the individual and the talent and the
the balls that we see aaron rodgers
throw and the winds and how much he
accounts for listen this is not a
conversation about evan rogers it's a
hall of famer one of the top
quarterbacks ever it's about his resume
the reason why we call tom brady to go
is because of championships tom brady
don't have a drop of the talent that a
lot of quarterbacks we've seen have tom
brady don't have elway talent he don't
have dan marino's talent he don't have
steve young's talent or aaron rodgers or
patrick mahomes but you know in those
moments where you need to be great
is what we judge these level of
quarterbacks on and that's why he's
considered to go he's considered the
goat because you would put all your
money in your house on tom brady in the
last drive of a football game to get his
team to a championship aaron rodgers has
not done that now i'm mad at matt
lafleur last year i believe that was a
lot on him of not letting him have the
ball in his hands in in the fourth
quarter but he also had three turnovers
he also gave the ball away in that game
as well so i don't i don't just
subscribe to you know individual talent
as making you to go as far as what did
you do how did you elevate in those
particular moments i fight with dan
olavsky about this all the time okay
he you know he goes to bed for every
quarterback because every quarterback is
good in the nfl
but i tell him all the time man we not
judging carson wentz on if he can throw
a touchdown in the first quarter of a
football game when you on your first 15
play script and it's hard as hell for
the defense to figure out what you're
doing we judge carson wentz when you're
down to jacksonville and you throw two
damn interceptions or you make a
bonehead play in fumble the football we
judge baker mayfield on the cleveland
browns are good and they get the ball
into the fourth quarter and he throws an
interception in the kansas city game or
he can't get it done and then that's
where we judge quarterbacks we see aaron
do that all year long and for some
reason in these nfc championships he
cannot overcome that hurdle so we'll see
if he can this year i believe he can i
don't think his talent lends itself to
not having that ability he just hasn't
done it
we're talking to marcus spears uh nfl
nfl live monday through friday at four
eastern and also they have their wild
card game that'll be the cardinals in
the room
i know look at you i know that's not a
it's not a that's not a good look not a
good look i got you you sacked brady in
2011.
yeah is that right
yeah i didn't even remember what
happened dp i was just
like sometimes you know i tell people
all the time man playing football
sometimes the play happened and it feel
like you're blinking it's over i whooped
i whooped the offensive lineman whoever
was in front of me and brady just
happened to be in the way of the freight
train you know so
hey i got hit believe this dp i i i was
not a sad guy i was considered a bus
because of my draft pick because you
know if you don't get over 90 sacks then
you sucked in your whole career like
playing the run and doing all of that
stuff does not matter in the grand
scheme of things but i did hit drew
brees i sacked drew brees i sacked ben i
sacked brady i hit aaron um gotta got a
pressure on him i think i've sacked all
of the guys that's gonna go to the hall
of fame or at least got a big hit on
them so i feel really good about that
how tough was roethlisberger to bring
down he was bigger than me
it's like it's like uh you know i'm
watching this this this show called
yellowstone which is one of the greatest
shows ever i don't know if you guys have
watched the dp if you have any time
watch yellowstone i've been watching
it's like when them dudes jump off that
damn horse and they trying to uh wrangle
them little them little calves
that's how it is trying to tag a big man
man
[Laughter]
i liken him to uh king kong he's on the
empire state building yeah and those
planes that come around him he just
keeps swatting them he's
people don't realize how big certain
quarterbacks are
and also certain like cam newton
when when
him and kelvin benjamin walked on the
field i i thought
i thought it was a basketball team
i thought it was you know it was a
basketball team yeah man yeah listen dp
when we play so
uh funny story i played ben when i was
at lsu we played miami ohio when ben was
in college
and i remember nick saban telling us hey
this guy's going to be a top top pick
he's a very good football player and
he's big so you better bring all you
have when you get in there to get him on
the ground so being has been like this
dp you people look at the game and they
wonder why being can't move because ben
has taken hits from guys the same size
as him for a long time and he still i
don't know how the hell he in the
playoffs and i would i
you got to be crazy to say that ben has
no chance in the playoffs all right
speaking of what we were talking about
earlier because i've seen him do this
too many times
great to talk to you as always love the
energy have a great weekend and uh we
hope to talk to you soon thank you bp
send me one of them trinkets man i love
it what do you want what do you want i
don't know the the
if that's not the old mic that you use
when you first started doing radio then
i like that right there i just want
something so next time i'm on your show
you can see one of yours on my from my
feet well why don't you send a jersey
and then we'll put a jersey here in the
man cave and then when you come on
we go to i know greenie doesn't put up
one of your jerseys in the man cave
there no
no i told i told you the first time i
don't fool with greenie like that
everybody think i do i don't i don't me
me and g ain't all that tight like that
no i'm just playing he just got jaylen
rose you know he got all of these guys
that everybody knows he's got to be
super famous
you know dan arlovsky offered me a
jersey and i declined
[Laughter]
your show might be council
i said i'll take the jersey where you
ran out of the end zone during a play
that's the one i want with orlovsky
get him bp love you brother thank you
man thank you thank you that's marcus
spears uh
i love the energy